so dave robinson did a kind of like live
analysis of
this like dog breed
data and he made a shiny amp out of it
so maybe i can walk through
what it looks like in pie shiny and just
try to translate some of that to pie
shiny so i i watched him work with this
data so i i know a little bit about it
and for some context there's i think
there's a little bit of cleaning that
has to happen and then some reshaping
the interesting thing so
as i understand
there's three pieces of data you have
these breed traits so this is um
for each breed of dog
uh it's like ranked or it's i think it's
rated on a number of things like
how good are you with young children
apparently retrievers are really good
norwegian
lund tons are not not the best then
there's the trait description i think
this is a pretty wild one
this is um
just written out description so and i
actually love this like um
so for affectionate with family if you
get a five it means your lovey dovey
which i find to be just great so a
yeah so retrievers lovey-dovey and then
breed rank all
is um this is a little bit different
this is like
from 2013 to 2020 or 2020 um
rankings of the dogs
basically over time what we can look at
is maybe like comparing
dogs across traits and working on like a
shiny app that
lets you kind of like because there are
a lot of dogs
here if you look at the breed traits
so it'd be nice if a user could choose
the dogs they want to look at
and be able to compare them
in a plot there's a little bit of
wrangling here's a weird thing i can
either wrangle it in suba or
pandas for me suba is the most fun so um
and i'm pretty used to it so basically
this is a port of
i maintain from d plier to
python
and i've kind of come to rely on it as a
thing that just kind of like wraps
pandas and does a little bit on top of
pandas
to make life a little easier so
the way it works is um
pretty similar to d plier with a couple
twists so
um
for example like if i want to find
a dog that's not very affectionate
uh with family i these columns are crazy
i might have to fix that but um
i could do like where it's
one
you know so okay so like the anatolian
shepherd dogs apparently they're very
uh like independent so
the key with suba is that um
like with deep wire
it would look like
pretty similar you'd have a pipe
and then you'd have like
this just by itself
something like this
so the big differences are um
now the pipe's like a greater than
greater than sign
and we're using like an underscore
rather than referring to the columns um
directly
uh
this is just because it's way easier for
me to just keep thinking in d plier than
to
kind of switch
um and it's not that different from
pandas pandas would be like breed traits
affectionate
with family
and then you'd do something like this
there are a few ways to do it
um
so it's kind of like there's always like
a pretty sim like
pretty s the translations to pandas
aren't crazy but
it just cuts out some writing
basically
the other useful things and i'm i'm
cheating because i saw dave
work this with this but um
for reshaping
uh it'd be nice to tidy this so that um
a lot of these columns become
uh to go from wider to longer so
it'd be nice if like a lot of these were
a column called measure and then these
things were a column called say value
um
one of the big things we have to do
though is that this
like these are all numeric
so they're it makes sense that we could
reshape them we've got to drop things
like this that are
use a different
uh uh kind of measurement so
[Music]
do select
um
and i'll use the minus sign to remove
things actually first i'm gonna
i think clean up these column names so
there's a pie janitor library which is
nice that can claim names
or i guess we can um
see
it'd be something like
uh
i always forget how to do this i think
you could do something like
this is crazy but um
i think this will do
basically to snake case let's see
it's something bad
columns
yeah so this is pretty gnarly pandas
code but the trick is that um
this gives you back
uh index of columns
and then
indexes and series and pandas have these
string methods
so you do like string.lower
and then you can kind of like keep going
so this is i would probably just use
in other situations maybe pi janitor
like it's nice in the tidy verse there's
just a clean names function um
to get rid of a lot of this but i'm just
gonna
need to find it here oh that's bad
uh
i'm just gonna put it
here i'm i think i'll just
mutate it uh
because life's too short so
um
that should
do it and i'll just return it
um
and
uh
so this
black i have black formatting set up
which gets kind of weird i might turn it
off but um
oh this is bad
i got a
auto format good one save the notebook i
think that'll
do it
okay we're back
all right sorry so that's weird
um so that's what's doing a lot of this
formatting
um
i don't really know the weird thing
between r and python is i'm
not really sure how to
r it's kind of nice you can like quickly
the one funky thing about python is to
do the pipes with nice format you kind
of gotta um
use these parentheses around them
um
so i'm just gonna pipe this uh
using this pandas method
sorry this is kind of crazy
so
it's
okay great so now we've got
nice formatted names
um
[Music]
and all of that's just so in this select
i can now
uh
just drop
using like code type
and drop
code length
so i think now we have everything and we
can
reshape so what i'll do is um
gather it
uh which so the first argument is the
name of the new
column that all of these will be put in
so these names
and then
the measure column
and then i think that we just
say everything we want so
negative means we want everything except
for the breed column to be reshaped
so now
we've gathered
me
three trades
now we've taken all these columns and
basically like
i don't know i don't know how to use
human
words for that but um
so now each
each measure is
right here so each of these cells and
now the columns are in this measure
column
um
this will be useful for the app because
i'm going to call this traits long i
guess
um
is that this makes it a lot easier to
select things um now we can just filter
to keep specific columns
or filter to keep specific uh breeds so
i think that's the big d player thing is
like before
we could filter by breed or select a
column the beauty of gathering is now we
can filter
either of these things breeder
measure i'm going to rename measure to
trade
so
all right great so now we have this data
um
we can visualize it i'm going to use um
plot9
so plot9 is a port of uh gg plot two
um
it's super nice i think it's been around
for a long time and it's a super
faithful
port so basically
all of this is me trying to like squint
my eyes and produce
uh what seems like tidy verse code
uh
so
all right so
um
let's see let's just
trace long
uh
gg plot
so i'm going to uh actually we need to
filter it probably so let's get just
maybe a couple breeds
[Music]
so i'm gonna use the pandas method is in
so that's like
get it from this list so let's say
labrador retriever
scared french bulldogs
double check that worked
oh something bad happened let me
i wonder if this is a little bit um
i need to somehow see it as a list i
think that okay so this is a weird thing
uh
this is a great data wrangling problem
uh
i don't this is a character that appears
as a space but is it uh
i don't sometimes you can google these
things and it'll show people will
explain like what
is happening but usually just string
replace them so
um
let's see i
i'm just gonna do it yeah i'm just gonna
like remove
or replace
space or something
like a column
wait i don't care i'm just gonna put in
the mutate okay so
uh
let's put it here for now just to see
um
so we selected we gathered let's just
replace it here and see how this goes
uh
i think it's just this character and
then
let's see if this works
okay so yeah visibly like no change but
i'm guessing this will let us
uh
let's see
yeah great that was a real
hot scary
issue
uh
cool okay so this got it and then
so i'm going to filter maybe um
[Music]
i'm just going to keep
say like affectionate
family and
good with young
children
okay
i'm gonna
so
um
black format this
it's using this um jupiter
uh what's it called jupiter code
formatter
library
um
cool so now we've got two traits two dog
breeds
we can plot it so
g plot
uh
on the x-axis probably trait
y-axis probably value and then
i'm gonna um
make a bar chart and then
i'm gonna make breed its own
plot let's take that oh something bad
happened
uh oh i'm sorry geombar
counts up the values gm call makes a
column
okay so this isn't super exciting there
are fives on
both of these uh
but this is maybe a nice example because
there's a lot of room for improvement so
uh
one thing i'd like to do is um
fulfill the breed
or the trait
um
this just kind of like recodes this
information but makes it easier to see
and then um
the weird thing is this text is
horizontal so we can um
change it in the theme i think it's like
axis text
x
and then this kind of tricky gg plot
thing element text
angle is 45
um
and then
the last thing this is probably the most
common thing i do in ggplot is um
notice that it it kind of be nice if
this end character like matched up with
this
and i think that's just
h just equals one i don't even honestly
these this is like this very snippet i
use so much that i just
like reflexively
slam it every time
um oops
so
okay so we've got plots uh we did like a
little bit of cleaning
a little reshaping
um i think so this is something dave did
i think it's like perfect like this
would be a nice kind of like
starter for a shiny app like
we did like a little analysis
we made our plot
um
but now it would be so nice if we
basically could um
select the breeds and select the traits
there's this weird thing like if you
watch people build shiny apps actually i
think the most intriguing part is they
often have like analysis code somewhere
and then like shiny app code i think
this is actually one of the hardest
parts of starting with shiny is the
workflow like
having your analysis on one side and
your
app on the other
jubi text
no i don't let me install this really
fast
uh
what i often end up doing is um
text so
this is the code
um
what i can do is um
say 2p text
one thing i like to do sometimes is i
just put the shiny app at the bottom of
the notebook so
um and the way i do this is um
you can pair the notebook with something
called light script
and notice that when i save it it
produces a python
file so now what happens is like
basically i just want to keep exploring
but i'm going to tuck a shiny app like
down
below i don't know if this is a good
idea or if it'll even work but um
and i'm going to add a section like
exploration okay so now the trick is
that now i have my exploration code up
here and jupiter has this nice um
table of contents so i just marked like
oh this is my exploration code
this is my app
so i can jump between them
and then uh what i'm gonna do is i'll
just scaffold out like a really
tiny shiny app
and then i'll just run the whole script
um
because like life's too short i just
i i kind of want to just do the
exploration and the app in the same
place uh
i'm gonna copy out
maybe from the
i mean this link won't exist in a month
but um
just this tiny app
uh
okay so
so the key is like this doesn't do
anything really because shiny
needs the cli the command line interface
to run
but it's kind of nice like it's all in a
notebook and then what i'll do is um
i'll run it separately
uh
so
you could also do this in the jupiter
lab
terminal that might be a good
i should down there but um
dog app
so i'm just gonna run
oh i don't remember how the cli works uh
shiny run i think
i'll keep looking at the help docs uh
so the thing is i want to run shiny run
but then i also want to run this reload
so that it auto reloads
so shiny run
analysis dot pi
and
reload
okay i might need to also
set the port depending on okay so
basically what's happening now is it it
executed this notebook
so just to back up this notebook through
jupytex is now saved also as a python
file every time i click save
it syncs with the python file
um
shiny cli is just running that
file
and the reason that's useful to me is
i'll just put like a lot of exploration
code in here
and i'll define the app down here
and then i'll just check over here to
see
like what the app
looks
like so
all right and it's kind of convenient
because a lot of shiny apps i just dump
this stuff straight in you know i can
like kind of like dump it in and then i
can clean it up and move it into its own
file if it's useful so like for example
we already have traits long so
i could just even put
this in let's do like a render
uh
see return like traits
long i think that uh so where we are
right now is that um
rendering tables is still a little bit
is in the works but um
so right now it's rendered as a ui
[Music]
let's just see what happens
when i just i'll drop in the plot
instead so
uh
let's see so i'm just gonna dump in this
plot code
just paste it in
um
here
and i think this should just show up
i'll do render plot
output
plot changes this isn't a table anymore
this is like a
trade graph
this trade graph
see
i love it still has this rogue
input
so um
i'm not seeing anything and that tells
me probably that there's an
error or something so
i'll look here
i don't see anything it's probably
something i did i think the
i didn't return it all right so
this is the graph we have this kind of
useless input now we have this like
hard-coded
thing
what i'd probably do next is i'd
like swap out these hard-coded things
for a
like dynamic input so
um
if you do input ink it select ties and
i'm going to call this traits
and
so this is the label that'll show up on
the input and then
uh so many options choices here so
windows multiple
equals true
and choices
equals
what we could do here is we could
actually set these as the choices to
start just to make sure things wire up
um
let's just see that it worked
cool so the choices are here
they're not wired up yet but this is a
kind of a nice i think for me sanity
check that
it's like ready to go and so now i'll
just swap out this for um input dot
traits so this thing here
just to link it up
all right so
yeah so the move was kind of like i set
the choices i copied the choices from
here to here and then i like swapped in
the
interactive piece
uh cool
so now we can see
like i can toggle it which is great
um
this is still kind of boring because i
just hard coded two
choices
so the
a nice move here is you can actually
just hard code
the choices based off the data so if i
go to like traits long dot traits unique
let's show this
it's trait
okay so this just gets me each unique
trait
and then the last thing i need is shiny
i think wants it as a list so i'll just
use this pandas method to list
um
so what i'll do is i'll probably do like
um
options traits
or something trait
yeah
options trait
so now it's all of the
traits um
the data
so now we can see like
for a french bulldog or retriever um
different uh things about i'm gonna make
this little
bigger
um
nice so we have the traits wired up
uh
let me go ahead and try to
set the breeds now so
uh
i'm just going to do the exact same
thing but drop in
breed
sorry for this trait maybe
and just paste in the exact same thing
[Music]
and then because it worked out okay for
the other i'm just going to jump
straight to it input dot reads
so
this is not right
uh
[Music]
so i did something bad let's see oh i
put
the traits here so
options breed
yeah that's cool i'm partial to beagles
do we have corgis
oh we got we got multiple
kinds
uh
yeah i love that pembroke
welsh corgis seem a little
more affectionate you know cardigan
welsh corgi is a little bit
too independent i don't know
um
yeah that's nice i think the
autocomplete's great like um
being able to search super fast
[Music]